avez vous déjà eu un voisin très bizarre
qui parle tout seul qui crient ou qui a
l'air suspect et bien aujourd'hui ça va
être le cac40 air le soir qui fait
toujours la gueule fait du bruit mat
inquiet tout anxieux que tous pas les
voir parce que tu as peur qui débute
bref le voisin chez les lourds
aujourd'hui on est sûrs et launay bon
nous sommes dans notre petite maison
c'est le soir et c'est ce voisin d'en
face le match où on le suspecte de faire
un truc bizarre dans son sous-sol
cache-t-il des prisonniers fait-il
poussée de la bonne nous le saurons bien
assez agressés par des sceaux talent ok
nous voici donc devant chez lui la
difficulté du jeu c'est que le mec
s'adapta manière de jouer
moi je pourrais je regarde à travers au
premier abord repère un petit peu excite
la hyène sortie ok je vais aller voir
derrière cia pas quelque chose là il ya
une porte derrière on peut ouvrir assez
verrouillé ses lauriers
alors comment on peut faire pour rentrer
cette [ __ ] de maison c'est shawn on
doit écouter je propose qu'on fasse la
méthode gentil jean matouk est ok je
suis dans la cimade jade c'est quoi
cette maison bizarre c'est l'entrée elle
est grande ouverte ce qui est bizarre
c'est quoi ça ces caméras rien et là oh
regardez comme c'est encombre eric et
délires totalement c'est sûr ils
échouent excès d'accord et manichéen et
maintenant il fait jour ok alors mon
pote et regardent la télé il est là il a
pleine gueule de make you loose ok j'ai
sonné jeu qu'on va se battre on va
trouver une entente remake tu es super
bowl un trophée ok on peut prendre des
objets avec fg pris une tomate mais qu
il a envie devant la télé s'est calmée
way séquelles mais je peux lancer salah
non merde pénale est paru à temps on va
analyser à travers les insectes war en
fait les choses bien qu'il est là que je
puisse moi j'ai fait cette pièce
ok il va aller voir là bas comme ça on
peut rentrer
what may cry wolf wolf rigaux j'suis
cacher et des tomates reprise des
tomates est que pour une toile dans mon
inventaire pour une lancée ok ces
moments je suis bloqué [ __ ] de pandore
est ouverte je peux me barrer par là
c'est cool par contre la chute bloqué
offre non non hilale jeunes non j avais
tu prennes un cytomètre m'ont pas fait
gaffe parce que tu fais il va venir
revenir par là et moi je vais repasser
par l'autre côté ok ok ok alors fondé
juste qu'on trouve un début une piste
part où aller à pita maintenance et la
nuit qui va commencer à trouver autant
qu'il tranquille là on est à la rue
dufferin du tout en rejetant une thomas
dans ta gueule sale bâtard hockey et
attend avec je m'en fous je veux savoir
ce qu'il ya dans ce sens je m'en bats
les couilles frères ayew c'est quoi ça
c'est un piège à loup les mecs
tfou pourquoi tuer des pièges à loup
dans son jardin mais ce père d'un fils
de [ __ ] fait [ __ ] toi qu'il est ok ok
je prends la bouteille ah ok en fait
planter ses primes et les pièges des
caméras est tous d'accord il s'adapte
vraiment à ce qu'on fait en fait le gars
il a mis un digicode et tournant mais le
gage d'un match est dans la rue je dois
la rue je suis dans la rue à gré sur la
tuque malgré cela elle tu peux pas
question maintenant dublin c'est un
piège à l'oubli avant la presse oui
intrusion chez moi ok c'est participer
ne faut pas lui laisser le temps de
s'adapter snow midi millepied georges
tout ça devient la main alors donc il
n'a pas encore mis les jours c'est pas
de caméra il est toujours devant il a
rien vu le court donc on va rentrer en
keyes on a réussi à infiltrer une
nouvelle pièce d'accord c'est quoi ces
deux garages il n'y a rien d'anormal et
rana normal le garage symbian utile du
coup ok suivant au [ __ ] c'est quoi ça
ça c'est une autre pièce inutile avec
plein de poule je suis sûr qu'ils
impulsent vous servir aux vins produits
on va vers une pièce concernant noir il
faudrait une ampoule c'est sur ok o o
a priori il nous a pas encore vu c'est
une chance qu'on aille là à gauche sans
qu'ils nous voient au fils de [ __ ] ok tu
sors de fournaise et rien d'autre un
ballet qui chutent avec un balai je m'en
bats les couilles je m'en bats les
couilles excellent non le problème c'est
qu'il ya un code sur la porte et cite là
où il ya une clé là aux mondiaux projets
en pagaille et attend faudrait que je la
tire de l'autre côté de la maison c'est
si je la tire là bas à temps merde je
vois rien beaunois s'échoue ok ça mais
j'ai redémarré jeu et d'après ce qu'on
peut voir et de ce que j'ai lu en gros
il ya quatre éléments a chopé pour
pouvoir ouvrir cette porte là voilà elle
est entrouverte et je crois que la
première nuit de façon tu es obligé de
perdre dans tous les cas on y va on veut
ouvrir et il apparaît que marginaux but
à partir de là le vrai je commence et
voyez là barricadé la porte ce petit stp
voilà du coup il faut un marteau pour
péter la planche trouver le code est la
clé qui est ici bon et sous les yeux
pour déverrouiller le cadenas et ça je
peux vous dire que c'est chaud à
marteaux logiquement apparaît garde
vendredi je vous trouve ça peut être un
[ __ ] de marteau attend une lampe
torche ça peut être très utile par
contre non ça c'est rien ça c'est
beaucoup moitié ok nice on a une lampe
torche c'est bien ici à quoi il ya
[ __ ] je pense pas bah je suis piégé
milan fils de [ __ ] l'accusée primaire
devront c'est raté c'est pas grave on
est tous et je vous jure qu'on y arrive
je m'en bats les couilles là j'ai toute
ma journée je finirai pas ce véto qu'on
n'a pas réussit bon là il va être
beaucoup plus prudent et même commencé à
mettre des caméras cette espèce de
psychopathe de merde
est-ce qu'on peut pas passer par
ailleurs une porte d'ailleurs peut-être
une fenêtre un truc non attends j'ai une
idée
on va lancer à thomas dans le piège non
d'accord c'est bon c'est passé où elle
marc touya pas marteau là y'a juste la
langue qu'est la [ __ ] c'est infernal
la laci serait moment d'aller choper la
clé est d'ouvrir le cadenas et quand tu
t'y attends pas pourquoi tout ce sur
quoi on va chanter la clé aubry ouvre au
oui louvre pas ok c'est bon ça s'est
ouvert aux alors j'espère juste qu'il
apparaît mulkhan à ce qu'on il a remis
le cabanon il faut trouver le marteau et
le code et on est bon [ __ ] on va y
arriver ok qu'est ce qu'on a ici
yes ces lampes uv le code le code le
code de code le code le code non non
[ __ ] mais où tu caches un code non non
au 46 85 40 et 85 ok ok le manche le
marteau le marteau non mais n'a coché
sacoche était accroché trois hommes
bakiev je m'adore ok c'est bon lendemain
voilà ça permet qui nous choque pas et
qui renforce pas sa maison ça il faut
qu'on trouve le marteau il reste juste
le marteau 46 grâce à l'alcool mais je
m'en souviens mieux que ma date de
naissance le marteau il doit dans le
garage je pensais sur os
allez petit à m'agacer le bateau le
marché doit y est on à tarte aux pommes
et je m'en bats les couilles il arrive
pas nous trouver
on va foncer up les as 44 85 maires dans
c'est quoi pour toi oui non non mais non
mais ça valait le coup hommage à un
terme à cette notion est l'honneur
n'hésitez pas à aller mais ça vous a plu
ce jeu est génial c'est super bien que
le mec s'adapta manière de jouer que à
chaque fois que tu parlais rajoute des
pérics et a en plus un voisin un port
gentil parce qu'à chaque fois que qui te
prend la main dans le sac tita sauvy te
mets dans ton lit tranquillement et au
lendemain quand tu faire tourner l'insu
peut renforcer la sécurité il n'appelle
pas la police ne fait pas la gueule
tranquille eh ben c'est bien fait trop
les voilà le jeu qui te trouve le plus
au monde merci lots neighbor des
développeurs je vous offre ce truc pour
augmenter décibels à micro-ondes
évidemment c'est eux qui ne servent à
rien allez alors une prochaine vie
offerte pour tout le monde non